you look amazing you look fantastic
thanks I'm wearing your suit this is
when David Byrne was on the golden girl
it was I have to say you know you look
absolutely stunning is this can I may I
touch I'm just like silk what is that I
didn't make it I don't know I thought
people always had to know what they were
where they I know what I'm wearing Sears
not the material I don't know whether
they know I'm liking your Sharp new look
- oh thank you very much
cool like a I'm a substitute yes I am
I'm the substitute teacher that will
sell you we'd totally and used to play
bass yeah some nights he's definitely
Amelia Earhart we have so much to talk
about first of all it was lovely seeing
your your your husband backstage yeah
he's like the most charming handsome guy
I've ever met in my life
sorry yeah I know I want a shot at that
guy no no he's doing incredibly cool is
but the best part about him is that he
used to be like very ugly until he was
wait no I saw this guy no that's not a
hideous monster really until he was like
in his 20s right so he's got the soul of
a funny like funny looking guy but yeah
he he glowed up as the kids say yeah
yeah that's true because if people are
too handsome this is why I avoided
I like that they're alright with me that
clip we just showed and I've been
watching the series it is fantastic
thank you do an amazing job and you're
an amazing actor but this role that
you've inhabited it's a bit of a
challenge because you're you're taking
on this role obviously made famous in
misery by Kathy Bates and you're you're
taking on this role but you're really
making it your own and you've done it in
so many amazing ways where it feels like
you're somewhat paying homage to that
but you're really taking it in different
directions which is so cool like you've
changed the way you walk yes yeah I do a
strange waddle yeah yeah you know but
everything about it and and the way you
speak and everything you really
transformed yourself and I would Conan
well I looks and I know nothing about
acting I just know when I'm blown away
and I was I was just like floored by
this performance and one of the things
thinking was is it hard for you or you
one of those people it has to go into a
trailer and turn off all the lights and
become this character or I wish the
answer was yes because then people would
maybe take me slightly more seriously
but no no in fact my husband was on set
one day and I was covered in blood and
it was a very intense scene and then
this actress of speaking to a guest
actress and she was very serious about
the whole process and we were going over
everything and then I stopped her
mid-sentence because I saw craft service
and my husband watch me just run after
them going intending to say I like that
yeah I mean it's just so funny when
different acting Styles Clash I own
you've got someone there who's
pretending I've got to stay in the
character no one talks to me you're not
like that